what's the most powerful social media in
the world YouTube Instagram Tik Tok well
there's definitely a strong argument to
be made about each and every one of
those platforms but I would argue that
the most powerful social media Network
in the world is actually MSN Messenger
MSN Messenger is I'm just kidding I'm
actually talking about LinkedIn if
you're not familiar with LinkedIn
they're a professional networking site
owned by Microsoft where people can
share their career progression with
friends family and recruiters from
potential future employers today
LinkedIn boasts a whopping at 950
million members from more than 200
countries and territories around the
world for perspective WhatsApp has over
2 billion monthly active users and
YouTube has 2.7 billion monthly active
users so LinkedIn is obviously not the
most popular social media platform in
the world but when we look at Power it's
a completely different story take
revenue for example in 2022 WhatsApp
pulled in a total of $96 million in
Revenue this translates to a little less
than 50 cents per user per year LinkedIn
on the other hand pulled in
$14.59 billion in 2022 this translates
to over $15 in Revenue per user per year
or over 30 times more than WhatsApp
WhatsApp would need over 60 billion
users to pull in the same Revenue as
LinkedIn even YouTube only only pulls in
a little less than $11 per user per year
and a lot of people spend their entire
lives on YouTube with LinkedIn the vast
majority of users just check in here and
there and the craziest part is that
Microsoft didn't pay all that much for
LinkedIn then Facebook paid for WhatsApp
when all was said and done Facebook paid
a total of $22 billion for WhatsApp
while Microsoft paid $26.2 billion for
LinkedIn Microsoft clearly got much more
bang for their Buck but the power of
LinkedIn goes much deeper than just
monetary gain today LinkedIn is
synonymous with not just professional
networking but power control and
influence within the corporate world let
me
[Music]
explain Microsoft has clearly built a
massive social media platform behind the
scenes but that's not the only thing
that they've been building over the past
15 years Microsoft has grown their cash
reserves from $3 to $40 billion to $130
to $140 billion if you're wondering how
they responsibly store and maintain so
much cash well their secret is bonds
such companies often own tens of
billions if not hundreds of billions of
dollars worth of government and
corporate bonds which are currently
yielding 4 to 7% per year if you look
for a modern platform to invest in bonds
yourself however you'll quickly find
yourself with no option and that's where
our bond investing app Silo comes into
play with Silo not only are your
deposits and Investments covered by
$500,000 in sipc insurance and $2.5
million in FDIC insurance but all funds
and financial activity is handled by our
trusted custodian ibkr who has 45 years
of experience managing over $350 billion
worth of assets so if you want the
safety and reliability of an experienced
financial institution combined with the
UI and the ease of use of a modern tech
company please consider checking out
Silo in the description below but anyway
taking a look back the story of LinkedIn
dates back to the early 2000s to a man
named Reed Hoffman LinkedIn likes to
claim that they were started in Reed's
living room and that's probably
technically true but make no mistake
LinkedIn was by no means a bootstrapped
startup not only did they have a stacked
team with a bunch of early PayPal
employees and executives but they also
had access to $123 million worth of
funding over the next several years so
you basically had the Dream Team paired
with virtually unlimited funding and
their goal was simple create a
business-oriented social media platform
they would call it LinkedIn and Linkedin
would make its debut on May 5th 2003
unlike other social media platforms
LinkedIn never really had some sort of
viral moment or explosion Instagram for
example racked up 20 5,000 users within
the first day 100,000 users within the
first week and a million users within
the first 2 months LinkedIn gr on the
other hand was a lot more modest they
ended the first month with 4,500 users
much of whom were invited by the
company's original employees but over
time these numbers slowly compounded
instead of getting thousands of users
per month LinkedIn started getting tens
of thousands and then hundreds of
thousands and so on likely the main
reason that LinkedIn never had a viral
moment was because of their demographics
but at the same time their unique
demographics are what make the platform
so special in the first place
technically you only have to be 16 years
old to create a LinkedIn account but I
don't think you'd be surprised to hear
that the vast majority of LinkedIn users
are above the age of 25 this is in stark
contrast to basically any other social
media platform with Tik Tok for example
30% of their users are under the age of
20 and another 30% are under the age of
30 YouTube's users tend to be a bit
older but we also have to keep in mind
what kid doesn't just lie about their
age moreover five out of the top 10 most
subscribed YouTubers make content for
teenagers and children there's nothing
wrong with this as YouTube and most
social media platforms are largely meant
for entertainment so it's not surprising
that younger people with more time tend
to use these platforms more actively but
when we look at this from a more cynical
perspective of what user base is more
lucrative and and useful to control it's
obviously the older demographic we
should also note that linkedin's user
base is not only older than other
platforms they're also way more
successful at least from a career
perspective I mean just think about it
what type of person would want to
publicize their professional life
obviously not someone who's a cashier at
Walmart or an ubber delivery driver it's
probably not even someone who has a more
modest job as a teacher or a police
officer or a nurse or even a doctor for
that matter linkedin's most active users
are the hyperco competitive type who are
playing the game of capitalism and
climbing the corporate ladder aka the
people with the most power control and
influence in the world by the end of
2004 LinkedIn would grow to house over a
million of these people but all of this
was just the
beginning moving into 2005 LinkedIn
would roll out the first stages of
monetizing this highly valuable user
base with the launch of LinkedIn jobs
over the years this has expanded into
three primary sources of revenue
starting with Talent Solutions this is
by far their largest source of Revenue
basically companies and recruitment
agencies pay LinkedIn to be able to post
their job listings on the website and
easily reach out to highly qualified
potential recruits after Microsoft took
over we haven't been getting as detailed
reports about linkedin's Revenue
segments but before they took over
Talent Solutions accounted for almost
2/3 of linkedin's Revenue aside from
Talent Solutions just like any other
social media platform LinkedIn also
makes money off of showing ads and let
me just say it's extremely expensive to
Market on LinkedIn in fact the average
cost of a LinkedIn ad is
$526 per click for perspective Google
ads on average only cost one to $2 per
click so LinkedIn ads are often three to
five times more lucrative than Google
ads but with that being said people
don't spend nearly as much time on
LinkedIn and there's not as many
companies who are interested in buying
these ads so ads only account for 18% of
linkedin's Revenue and this brings us
into linkedin's last major source of
Revenue which are premium subscriptions
for $30 to $60 per month LinkedIn users
can unlock additional functionality
regarding job postings and career
insights to be honest premium isn't all
that useful for most LinkedIn users but
this has has nonetheless grown to
account for 17% of linkedin's Revenue
over the years going through all of
these sources of revenue you probably
noticed one attribute that was extremely
apparent the intent of LinkedIn is
extremely focused you go there to
advertise about jobs hire for jobs look
for jobs talk about jobs spy on other
people's jobs it's all about jobs and
this is the second factor that makes
LinkedIn more powerful than any other
social media the intent and focus of
LinkedIn is extremely clear with other
social media platforms people use them
for all sorts of reasons from learning
and personal growth to entertainment and
comedy with LinkedIn however there's
only one reason to use it something job
related other than a few special people
no one actually uses LinkedIn for fun
they use LinkedIn with intent and focus
whether it's a company recruiter or
employee and given that jobs are the
primary way that the vast majority of
the world Mak all of their money there
is quite a bit of money being exchanged
on LinkedIn and as such maintaining and
facilitating this network has also
proven to be extremely lucrative
LinkedIn first became profitable all the
way back in March of 2006 for
perspective it took YouTube at least a
decade to achieve profitability and
Twitter Snapchat WhatsApp and Tik Tok
are still not profitable so LinkedIn is
very much the leader when it comes to
revenue and value per user but but not
everything about LinkedIn is quite as
rosy by 2011 LinkedIn had grown to over
a 100 million users and they were
pulling in more Revenue than Twitter so
they would decide to make things
official and go public with a valuation
of $4.3 billion in May of 2011 let's
just say that this IPO was extremely
successful as the stock market would
value the company at over double that at
8.79 billion dollars just a few weeks
later LinkedIn was officially a
mainstream social media platform but
they also started to develop a cringy
reputation you see LinkedIn became the
place where people would overstate their
experience and inflate their job titles
in hopes of catching the eyes of
recruiters and I'll be the first to
admit that there is definitely a cringe
Factor associated with LinkedIn but you
can say the same thing about any social
media with Instagram for example you've
got a bunch of people chasing clout and
portraying their lives as something
better than it is by posting half- naked
pictures and highlights of their
otherwise boring lives similarly with
Tik Tok you've got a bunch of thirst
traps and Mindless content that you
won't even remember 10 minutes later and
even on YouTube you've got a bunch of
clickbait and flexing but there's one
crucial difference between the cringe of
most social medias and the cringe of
LinkedIn with most social media the
cringe factor is a result of people
chasing something superficial whether
it's the appearance of being rich and
happy or the ego associated with having
a high follower count with Linkin on the
other hand the cringe factor is mostly
just a result of people wanting to
improve their careers as much as
possible the bottom line is that people
have realized that staying loyal to one
company and working for 40 years simply
does not play out all that well over the
long term even if the company treats you
well and you have a good working
environment it's more than likely that
your peers who conly switch jobs and
play the game end up in a much better
situation more and more people are
realizing this with each passing year
leading to more and more people joining
the game on LinkedIn trying to network
with as many people as possible getting
referrals contacting recruiters buffing
up profiles and so on this of course
leads to some pretty cringey posts and
sterile conversations across the
platform but hey it's all done with
mostly good intentions Microsoft started
sensing this trend pretty early on and
and they basically decided if you can't
fight this movement you might as well
join this movement and profit off of it
and that's exactly what they did in mid
2016 they went ahead and bought out
LinkedIn for a $26.2 billion all cash
deal at the time LinkedIn was pulling in
just under $3 billion per year today
they're pulling in just under $15
billion per year this of course doesn't
directly translate to market cap growth
but I think it's safe to say that
LinkedIn is worth around hundred billion
today and and this is not surprising
when you consider that they have a
billion people who are using their
platform with the sole focus of career
progression professional networking and
making more money and somehow this
insanely powerful platform is now also
owned by Microsoft and it's becoming
harder and harder every day to escape
Microsoft stronghold so maybe it's time
we adopt their strategy and instead of
fighting them we join them by investing
in bonds if that sounds valuable please
consider checking out Sil in the
description below but until then I'm har
and I'll see you guys on the next
[Music]
one